Now let's try to figure out Tomasulo timing on our own. Suppose we
have a processor with these latencies. A load takes one cycle to execute,
an add takes one cycle, and a multiply takes five cycle. Suppose that
the latencies of instruction execution are load one cycle, add one cycle, and
multiply five cycles. Suppose we also have this number of reservation stations.
We have one load reservation station, two add, and two multiply reservation
stations. And finally, we need to know what's allowed in the same cycle. And for
that, issuing and then dispatching instruction in the same cycle is not allowed.
Capturing the upper end and then dispatching the instruction in
the same cycle is not allowed in this processor. And finally,
if a reservation station is freed, it cannot be used in the same cycle again for
another instruction. So once we free a reservation station,
it only becomes eligible for issuing another instruction in the next cycle.
These are the instructions we have. And what we need to now do is figure out
the timing for them, when do they share dispatch and write. To get you started,
these four instructions will issue in cycles one, two, three, and four.
This quiz has two parts. Part one is for you to figure out for
this four instructions that issue in cycles one, two, three, and four. When do
they dispatch for each one of them and when does each of them write it's result?